we're in Big Fork Montana if you want
something sometimes you just have to
build it yourself that motto is the
foundation of our next stop the new
agrarian school this Forge is home to
some of America's most talented
blacksmiths and today we have their top
Smiths competing to represent both the
shop and me for a chance to become a
forged and fired Champion guys we want
you to build
this the double bit fing
X
since the 19th century the double bit
fing ax has been a favorite tool of
North American Lumberjacks revolutionary
because of its simplistic Design This ax
features two different heads one with a
thicker Edge designed for delivering
deep fing chops on massive trees and the
other with a finer Edge ideal for
dropping limbs making it essential for
life in the remote Wilderness this ax is
so synonymous with the American
Frontiersman it has even been featured
in the folktales of the giant Lumberjack
Paul bunion
gentlemen good luck we'll see you back
at our Forge in 4 days all right buddy
let's
go my game plan today is to forge my Axe
and then punching the
hole pretty clean cut Yep looks good
we're ready to do our hardening okay
here we
go I just quenched my ax everything went
great no warps no breaks so yeah we're
looking
good I am going to gun blue my axe the
gun blue gives it a nice black color so
it'll have a really nice contrast
between the dark body of the axe and
Polished out bits it could help put me
over the edge I'm cutting the slot for
my wedge this is the visible part of it
and you want to make sure that it's
right in the
center looking good
good I really love how this axe looks I
want to do the new agrarian School
proud probably the biggest tool I've
made is an 8lb Sledgehammer but I've
never made an axe of this size now that
I've Forge this Billet I want to punch
this eye by hand to make sure I don't
make a
mistake yeah I like how that looks I
just got into the parameters yesterday
in my forging and quenching next thing
to do is go ahead and drill a sign hole
from my axe eye to make parameters later
will have a pin to mechanically hold the
handle to the axe as an extra safety
precaution oh sh isn't it the the drill
bit basically destroyed itself I should
have drilled this hole through my axe
before I heat treated it because this is
hardened uh basically I need to heat up
the center of the eye there just to make
it softer now I'm going to go ahead and
quench it again this is a really
critical itical moment the blade could
crack or get real
warped it's pretty good so far I don't
see any signs of warpage feeling pretty
good about it I'm going to start working
on my handle it's important that this
fits tight mostly from a safety point of
view but also from a practical point of
view cuz if I want to win this thing I
got to put everything I've got into
building this ax I'm going to test this
by just cutting a small
happing uh I'm excited to represent
Jeffrey and the new agrarian school I'm
looking forward to the judge's
Forge so far I'm pretty happy with
it all right gentlemen first off we've
got a functionality
test I'll be taking your axes using both
bits and chopping into our log here
Peter you're up first are you ready I'm
ready
so right off Peter looking at your axe
the Symmetry is really nice everything's
got a really good shape to it the
handle's super comfortable very smooth
as far as the edges go one
Edge held up there's not any kind of
deflection on it the other Edge has the
smallest deflection but uh I feel like I
could definitely drop a tree with this
ax so nicely done thank you all right
silus you ready
yes
sir all right stylus right off the bat
this is a really really pretty
axe it's a little bit lighter in the
head the uh handle construction very
smooth a little bit more obtuse of an
edge than Peters which is a good thing
because there's no deflection or any
Edge damage at all so really well done
thank
you all right gentlemen we've had we had
our functionality test and that went
well so now it's time to have some good
oldfashioned fortun fire fun we're going
to test your weapons in a way that
they've never been designed to be tested
we're going to smash some into these
pots and that
can Peter you first you ready I'm ready
okay
[Music]
well Peter once you get momentum with
this axe man it's going but um your Edge
did take some damage here after the test
there's some rolling on your Edge
Edge where I can hook my fingernail on
it and then on the other Edge you've got
a couple small chips all in all
everything's still right and tight it
still feels good so nicely done thank
you all right silus ready I'm
[Music]
ready
all right sylus one of your edges has a
little bit of rolling to it not too much
still
sharp other side really didn't take much
damage at all
I really do like how smooth you got this
handle when I'm swinging it it just
travels through my hand really easily
it's comfortable to use you did a good
job thank you thank
you you have fun oh yeah you know
smashing things that's what I
do both of you guys did a phenomenal job
but the time has come for us to decide
which one of you will be moving forward
into the final leg fighting against
three other Smiths we pick up across
America and the Smith moving forward in
this tournament
is silus
congratulations now Peter you did a
great job you're a talented Smith but
unfortunately your blade did not make
the cut and Dave's going to tell you why
Peter this really came down to two
things the chip your blade took and then
the rolling on your Edge would
eventually affect its functionality and
those are the reasons we're letting you
go well Peter it's been an absolute
pleasure you're watching your work but
unfortunately your time in this
tournament has ended I want to say thank
you for coming out at this point in time
I'm going have to ask you to please step
off the forge floor
sure I'm really happy with the axe I was
able to make and how it performed this
is the first time I built an axe of that
size and caliber and I think that silus
is a really competent blacksmith I've no
doubt that moving on with the
competition he's going to do
well well Silas congratulations that
means you are one step closer to a
$220,000 check to go into your pocket
and $10,000 in Gears and supplies to go
to Jeffree Funk new agrarian School
Silas that means you are joining us in
the second leg of this tournament to
fight three of The Smiths that we're
picking up across America for the final
battle very well done man good job I'm
excited to move on to the next round I'm
naturally a competitive person Peter's
an incredibly talented dude and you know
it all came down to the testing and I
hope that I've made Jeffrey and Dave
proud this is certainly the nicest AE
I've ever made and I'm ready to bring my
all to the next
round
[Music]